Saint Patrick's Day is celebrated all around the world.
But its true meaning can be overshadowed by leprechauns, three - leaf clovers, and wearing the color green.
I believe there's some confusion about exactly what are we celebrating on Saint Patrick's Day.
The main point of Saint Patrick's Day is not about being Irish per se,...
...even though that's part of it.
But it's about mission.
A mission detailed in two letters Saint Patrick wrote in the 5th century.
Father Billy Swan is studying the letter's theological and spiritual content.
Father Swan says the saint details the main events in his life,...
...particularly one that changed it all.
When he was just 16 years old growing up in Britain,...
...pirates kidnapped Saint Patrick and took him to Ireland as a slave.
But after six years, he managed to escape.
And then he tells us an amazing thing that, after a while of being at home again,...
...he felt his call to return to Ireland and to bring the Gospel to the Irish people,...
...to the people who had taken him captive.
Father Swan says his patron saint wanted to include the Irish people in the family of nations...
...who would know God's salvation at the end of time.
But Saint Patrick would face many obstacles.
Yet, he still had a great success and baptized thousands of people to the Christian faith.
His life always fascinated me from the time I heard of it as a child in school.
The teachers always used to tell us the story about Saint Patrick, coming up to Saint Patrick's Day.
And my fascination and admiration of his story and of his life...
...has continued up to this present day.
A life that's remembered 16 centuries later every March 17th,...
...the date believed to be the day he died.